I've never seen Game of Thrones I don't
have HBO I'm totally against cultural
phenomena I don't watch Game of Thrones
when my girlfriend does so all I know is
things that she's told me this is Game
of Thrones as I understand it having
never seen it Game of Thrones takes
place in medieval times but like magic
medieval times there are several royal
families the good guys are the
Lannisters and the bad guys are the
khaleesies there's either a prince or an
uncle and that's played by the guy from
the station agent and elf I think
someone who has really long blonde hair
um and she was kind of blue dress and I
only know that because I saw a picture
from Madonna wearing the same outfit
there's a giant named Hodor who's gay
and he carries around Peter Dinklage on
his back like the humungous from Mad Max
and then there's a really douchey prince
who everybody hates who's a kid didn't
he cut somebody's head off one time
maybe that was a thing they always do
and maybe he fell out a window one time
and I'm assuming there's like a lot of
sex on the show
there's always boobs on that show and
Peter Dinklage is always surrounded by
boobs and some Lannisters are doing it
with the khaleesies and Jon Snow is just
all in the mix at one point everyone has
dinner and they're all slaughtered all
of a sudden the story continues with new
characters that you didn't know the
posters now have a big black bird that
says people are dead or end of humans or
end of men and of men our men are done
something like that and Springs come on
so beware the Ides of Spring
to have 2y Z code or is gay
in real life he came out as gay